rücktritt nach plagiatsvorwürfen
bundesfamilienministerin gestolpert über
ihre doktorarbeit will aber in der
landespolitik durchstarten im frust in
praxen die ärzte brauchen schneller mehr
impfstoff und fordern deutlich weniger
bürokratie und eine mannschaft für die
em
bundestrainer löw und die weltmeister
muller und hummels zurück ins
nationalteam
die nachrichten nicht erst heute mit
christian sievers sind schon wund in 1
katja ist hier für den sport willkommen
bei uns hat die bundesfamilienministerin
gibt ihr amt auf franziska giffey spd
reagiert damit auf die affäre um
mögliche plagiate in ihrer doktorarbeit
gleichzeitig nimmt sie aber den nächsten
karriereschritt ins auge sie möchte im
herbst regierende bürgermeisterin von
berlin werden
gefallen bekommt ihren doktortitel im
jahr 2010 neun jahre später wird sie
nach plagiatsvorwürfen von der freien
universität berlin gerügt darf den titel
aber behalten
die kritik allerdings reißt nicht ab
seit 2020 läuft ein neues prüfverfahren
dabei steht weiter der drohenden entzug
des doktortitels im raum
heute morgen im kabinett bei der
bundeskanzlerin bittet franziska
gefallen dann offiziell um entlassung
als ministerin aus berlin frank buchwald
franziska giffey wagt die flucht nach
vorn
für die berliner spd zieht sie in den
wahlkampf vom amt der familienministerin
aber tritt zurück bedauern bei der
kanzlerin
ich habe mit franziska giffey in den
vergangenen jahren sehr gut und
vertrauensvoll zusammengearbeitet und
dafür danke ich ihr von herzen gefallen
politische karriere beginnt im berliner
problembezirk neukölln erst
schulstadträtin dann bürgermeisterin mit
klare haltung zur integration auf der
einen seite die hand reichen und auf der
anderen seite aber auch ganz klar sagen
es gibt auch ein stoppsignal für all
diejenigen die der meinung sind sich
nicht an bestimmte regeln halten zu
müssen
2018 wird sie familienministerin bald
danach gerät ihre doktorarbeit
wiederholt unter plagiatsverdacht
gefalle verzichtet auf den doktorgrad
und kontert auf facebook wer ich bin und
was ich kann ist nicht abhängig von
diesem titel was mich als mensch
ausmacht liegt nicht in diesem
akademischen grad begründet heute dann
der rückzug von der regierungsbank und
ein lob von spd-kanzlerkandidat scholz
sie hat ein großes herz und das hat
ihrer politik immer genutzt
sie hat großes engagement an den tag
gelegt und sie hat eine riesige
erfolgsbilanz als vermisste
familienministerin
dieses land nun übernimmt
justizministerin lambrecht auch das
familienministerium vertretungsweise
keine gute idee findet die opposition
wir haben immense soziale psychische
folgen der krone pandemie bei kindern
und jugendlichen
und dann muss das familienministerium
jetzt handlungsfähig seien
da reicht es auch nicht auf eine
vertreter lösung zu gehen gefahr selbst
äußert sich heute nicht vor der kamera
lässt aber wissen sie habe immer nach
bestem wissen und gewissen gehandelt um
das amt der regierenden bürgermeisterin
von berlin aber werde sie kämpfen
dann bringen wir unsere team in berlin
mit dazu in die sendung erst mal noch
kurz zu giggs stephan merseburger welche
strategie fährt sie denn da jetzt als
ministerin zurücktreten und gleichzeitig
in berlin antreten ist das so ein
bisschen augen zu und durch jetzt das
kann man so sagen auf jeden fall will
sie der entscheidung der freien
universität zuvorkommen und die so ist
ja im vorfeld durchgesickert wird ihr
die doktorwürde wohl aberkennen
sollte das passieren hatte gefahr im
vorfeld gesagt werde sie als
familienministerin abtreten aber als
bürgermeisterkandidatin antreten und
insofern hält sie worte die berliner
landes spd steht quasi geschlossen
hinter ihr
denn man hat gar keine alternative es
gibt keine andere kandidatinnen und
franziska giffey ist alternativlos sie
ist in der stadt sehr beliebt er hat
einen guten draht zu den menschen sie
gilt als kümmerin sie ist sozusagen die
hoffnungsträgerin der berliner spd und
und insofern eine alternative aber jetzt
hat sie eben diesen makel und diesen
makel wird der politische gegner im
wahlkampf genüsslich auskosten sagt
unser landespolitischer korrespondent
stephan merseburger guckt man die
bundespolitik und alaa jetzt soll die
justizministerin das familienressort
kommissarisch mit übernehmen welches
zeichen sendet das denn aus mitten in
der pandemie ja von außen betrachtet
sieht es natürlich auf den ersten blick
so aus als wolle man sagen das
familienministerium ist jetzt gar nicht
mehr so wichtig es gibt nichts nicht
viel wichtiges mehr zu tun für familien
das beißt sich natürlich mit der
lebenswirklichkeit
gerade von familien in dieser pandemie
wenn man dann mal hinter die kulissen
schaut dann ist diese vertretung lösung
nicht mehr ganz so nachlässig wie es
vielleicht auf den ersten blick
ausschaut denn es sind nur noch wenige
wochen bis zum beginn der politischen
sommerpause
danach nimmt der wahlkampf komplett voll
auf voll fahrt auf und dann ist das
gesamte kabinett so etwas wie ein
auslaufmodell echte großprojekte wird es
dann nicht mehr geben
damit relativiert sich das ganze
natürlich ein wenig allerdings muss man
sagen dass auf christine lambrecht jetzt
schon hohe erwartungen lasten denn es
gibt eben tatsächlich noch einiges zu
tun für familien in der pandemie sie hat
auch heute schon gesagt alles was an
projekten angeschoben worden ist vor
allem für familien möchte sie jetzt noch
umsetzen und darauf wird sie tatsächlich
auch jetzt noch einiges an kraft
verwenden das ist ein versprechen
darin wird nicht nur sie sich messen
lassen müssen sondern auch die spd
chocolat stefan vielen dank nach berlin
unser nächstes großes thema heute abend
jetzt die zunehmend drängende frage wie
kann in deutschland möglichst fair und
zügig weiter geimpft werden zunehmend
drängend weil in knapp drei wochen die
priorisierung wegfällt und weil immer
mehr impfstoff ins land kommt wurden von
januar bis märz noch 19,9 millionen
dosen geliefert so werden es von april
bis juni zusammen 80 millionen sein
allein bayern tag und moderner wollen im
juni gut 28 millionen dosen liefern
viel arbeit also auch für die hausärzte
die hatten zwar darauf gedrängt mit zu
impfen sehen jetzt aber große probleme
jana becker in der hausarztpraxis von dr
kuchen blumen stapeln sich die impfpässe
den gesamten mittwoch hat das praxisteam
in ratingen für die korona impfungen
verplant wir bekommen ständig e-mails
telefonate
nun da die impf priorisierung aufgehoben
wird haben die ärzte allein die
verantwortung für die im freien folge
tochter corinne blum ist klar dass er
auch nach dem siebten juni weiterhin
interne priorisierungen vornehmen wird
ja weil die vielleicht haus aus
risikogruppe sind oder wie auch immer
die bekommen natürlich schon
schneller einen termin seit beginn der
kroner impfung hatten sich die hausärzte
stark dafür eingesetzt in ihren praxen
impftermine vergeben zu können
kurz nach ostern waren die deutschen
hausärzte dann flächendeckend in die
impfkampagne eingebunden
nun melden sich mancher hausarztpraxen
wieder vom system ab da die nachfrage
nach terminen so groß ist werde die
stimmung von seiten der patienten nun
merklich aggressiver die frustration ist
groß das macht sich in den praxen
bemerkbar
wir würden impfen wenn wir im stoff
hätten so muss man es sagen
nun ist mit blick auf die anstehenden
sommerferien zusätzlich von einer
geringeren anzahl an geöffneten
arztpraxen auszugehen
außerdem rechnen sowohl praxen als auch
im zentren mit weiterhin bestehenden
engpässen bei der impfstoff lieferung
das kann konsequenzen haben
beispiel bayern was nicht mehr
stattfindet nach pfingsten sind die erst
impfungen da ist jetzt eine pause
eingetreten voraussichtlich werden die
impfungen anfang juni wieder deutlich
gesteigert
jetzt hoffen alle dass die unternehmen
auch wie versprochen liefern die zahl
der täglichen corona ansteckungen sinkt
weiter das robert koch institut meldet
11.000 40 neu infektionen innerhalb von
24 stunden das sind 3800 69 weniger als
vergangenen mittwoch es gibt 284 neue
todesfälle in verbindung mit cupid 19
die bundesweite sieben tage incident
sinkt auf 72,8 und die sinkenden
infektionszahlen machen das möglich
urlaub und tagesausflüge sind in vielen
regionen in deutschland wieder eine
option
in schleswig holstein hamburg und
niedersachsen liegt der
durchschnittliche inzidenz wert sogar
unter 50
übernachtungen sind wie hier in
scharbeutz also wieder möglich auch das
essen im und nicht nur vor dem
restaurant über pfingsten rechnet der
adac mit der ersten großen reisewelle
des jahres das wort reisewelle taucht
tatsächlich wieder auf unser nächstes
thema die situation im nahen osten die
beschäftigt uns jetzt und da zunächst
die nachricht dass innenminister horst
seehofer drei vereine verboten hat die
in deutschland den terror der hisbollah
unterstützt haben sollen
konkret sollen sie geld gesammelt haben
für sogenannte märtyrer familien also
hinterbliebene von getöteten attentätern
etwa die vereine hätten den kampf gegen
israel gefördert und damit gegen den
gedanken der völkerverständigung
verstoßen sagte der innenminister
im konflikt zwischen israel und
militanten palästinensern heute aus
washington ein deutliches signal an
israel
der us-präsident hat israels
regierungschef in einem telefonat
klargemacht dass er sehr bald eine zitat
signifikante deeskalation erwarte auch
im bundestag ging es heute um das thema
um antisemitismus hier in deutschland
und um die kämpfe vor ort außenminister
heiko maas verurteilte die angriffe auf
israel
er will jetzt in die region reisen und
selbst mit beiden konfliktparteien
sprechen
andrea solidaritätskundgebung für
palästina zur stunde in berlin der
konflikt im nahen osten spiegelt sich
weiter auf deutschen straßen im
bundestag am mittag eine aktuelle stunde
die kanzlerin die israels sicherheit zur
deutschen staatsräson erklärt hat ist
demonstrativ zugegen
der außenminister will noch heute nach
zu gesprächen nach israel fliegen
es gehe um frieden und sicherheit für
beide seiten wir sind deshalb der festen
überzeugung dass dies nur eine
verhandelte zwei staaten lösung sein
kann
an dieser lösung sei in den letzten
jahren zu wenig gearbeitet worden so
maas der bundespräsident äußert heute
zweifel an eigenen deutschen
vermittlungsbemühungen wichtig ist dass
wir wenn es um vermittlung geht nicht in
eine gegenseitige konkurrenz eintreten
wer kann möglicherweise am ehesten und
am besten vermitteln sondern dass die
internationalen bemühungen gut
koordiniert bleiben
explizit wandte sich steinmeier gegen
juden hast nichts was im nahen osten
gegenwert die stattfinde rechtfertige
angriffe auf juden in deutschland die
antisemitischen ausschreitungen nutzt
wiederum die afd
um heute im parlament stimmung gegen
muslime zu machen wir müssen den
antisemitismus im board aus der
islamischen welt stoppen
anstatt millionen von muslimischen
migranten ins land zu lassen sich gegen
antisemitismus wendet und eine und
stimmung macht gegen eine andere gruppe
nur weil sie muslimin sind betreibt die
sündenbock politik die wir kennen
von denjenigen die antisemiten sind wo
heute die demonstration für palästina
stattfindet ist morgen abend in berlin
eine große solidaritätskundgebung für
israel geplant zwischen spanien und
marokko gibt es neuen streit nach dem
ansturm von migranten auf die spanische
exklave fota dass marokko die grenze
dort nicht mehr kontrolliere zeuge von
mangelndem respekt sagt spaniens
premierminister
auch heute sind wieder flüchtlinge von
barock und nach sehr guter gekommen in
der hoffnung auf ein leben in europa
mindestens 8000 haben seit montag die
grenze überwunden fast 5000 von ihnen
wurden sofort wieder zurückgebracht
bislang war die deutsch russische
ostseepipeline nord stream 2 ein echter
konfliktpunkt zwischen den usa und
deutschland jetzt womöglich eine wende
offenbar will die regierung beiden auf
weitere sanktionen gegen die
betreibergesellschaft verzichten
das berichten jedenfalls us medien die
pipeline führt von sankt petersburg nach
lubmin in mecklenburg vorpommern bis zur
fertigstellung fehlen noch knapp 150
kilometer nord stream 2 soll jährlich 55
milliarden kubikmeter russisches erdgas
befördern
das würde europa zu stark von russland
abhängig machen argumentieren die usa
und dahin gehen wir jetzt noch für den
nachfrage nämlich zu elmar theveßen in
washington
da deutet sich ein wechsel an zumindest
in der politik nach außen heißt das dass
die us regierung jetzt ganz plötzlich
mit der pipeline aus russland
einverstanden ist nein die regierung
hier ist ganz und gar nicht
einverstanden hinter den kulissen hört
man weiter sehr klare worte zitat die
pipeline ist ein strategisches
projekt russlands um die sicherheit
europas zu untergraben ich glaube
deshalb dass es eher so ein taktisches
manöver ist nach dem motto aufgeschoben
ist nicht aufgehoben
joe biden erwartet von der
bundesregierung nach diesem
entgegenkommen für die anstehenden
gipfeltreffen im juni dann eben auch
volle unterstützung bei seinen
forderungen zum beispiel zum thema
klimaschutz aber auch zu einer
gemeinsamen haltung gegenüber den
militärischen provokationen und auch den
menschenrechtsverletzungen durch
russland und durch china andererseits
ist auch ein zeichen des guten willens
an wladimir putin joe biden will sich
unbedingt mit putin treffen bei einem
eigenen gipfel und dort natürlich die
großen konfliktthemen ansprechen und
wenn russland kommt und wenn russland
sich dann nicht bewegt dann so heißt es
hier könnte es dort zu massiven
sanktionen kommen
auch in sachen nordring 2 die analyse
von almaty wissens hätte hervor schenken
danke dafür
der kampf um rohstoffe auch wichtig beim
nächsten thema heute in zwei stunden
trifft sich der sogenannte taktische
lagert der staaten die an die arktis
grenzen oder dort interessen haben
offiziell soll es um gute zusammenarbeit
gehen aber es gibt brisante konflikte
zum rat gehören unter anderem die usa
kanada dänemark norwegen und russland
die russische regierung macht jetzt klar
sie will die kontrolle über öl und gas
und die vorherrschaft im äußersten
norden
das russische militär rüstet hier massiv
auf etwa auf franz josef land
unsere korrespondentin für begann dort
reise ins zentrum russischer macht
überlegungen das
verteidigungsministerium nimmt uns mit
auf eine pressetour zu seiner
nördlichsten militärbasis das praktische
kleeblatt auf franz josef land wurde
erst 2015 eröffnet und ist der stolz der
russischen nordflotte hier im äußersten
nordwesten russlands ist die nato ganz
nah kommt der feind hierdurch der kommt
hier nicht rechtlich wohl nicht
unbemerkt wir erwischen alle
die erschließung der immer wärmer
werdenden polarregion gehört seit jahren
zu den obersten zielen moskau in
russland steht man dem klimawandel
durchaus mit gemischten gefühlen
gegenüber
einerseits erhofft sich das land neue
ökonomische möglichkeiten sich neue
handelsrouten natürlich durch die
rohstoffvorkommen ist andererseits
fürchten dass schmelzendes eis neue
angriffspunkte heiligen könnte
russlands nordküste ist mehrere tausend
kilometer lang
moskaus besitzansprüche in der arktis
reichen umstritten weit darüber hinaus
und von seinen arabischen nachbarn fühlt
man sich hier zunehmend provoziert
[Musik]
norwegen unterstützt ungeachtet der
historisch gewachsenen
gutnachbarschaftlichen beziehungen zu
russland die erweiterung der
militärischen präsenz der nato
streitkräfte und eine zunahme des
konfliktpotenzials in der arktis die
aufrüstung der abt des lässt sich moskau
viel kosten wie viel genau bleibt geheim
weithin sichtbar sind die investitionen
dennoch nur so machen
machtdemonstrationen schließlich sinn
und direkt aus der akte ist jetzt nach
mainz sport ja wir können einen haken
hinter machen 26 sogar denn der 26 mann
kader für die fußball em steht thomas
müller und mats hummels sind wie bereits
spekuliert zurück im team
bundestrainer joachim löw überraschte
dann aber doch mit zwei namen christian
günther und kevin volland zum abschied
will joachim löw auf niemanden mehr
rücksicht nehmen alles dem erfolg
unterordnen
wir wollen eine mannschaft die vor
ehrgeiz sprüht die vor energie sprüht
die einfach auch mal das gefühl den fans
vermittelt dass da eine einheit auf dem
platz steht in der abwehr ist freiburgs
christian günther oben links neben mats
hummels die überraschung für die bank
der dortmunder die für die statik wir
haben diese entscheidung eben auch so
getroffen aus absoluter überzeugung weil
damals schon auch ein spieler ist der in
der abwehr auf andere spielern sehr
guten einfluss hat der in der
organisation gut ist und der natürlich
auch
turnier erfahrung mitbringen offensiv
ist neben müller auch kevin volland vom
as monaco wieder dabei 16 saisontore
haben löw überzeugt joachim löw ist mit
diesem kader über seinen schatten
gesprungen ist zum klaren
leistungsprinzip zurückgekehrt müller
und hummels sind zurück weil sie
sportlich überzeugt haben
draxler brandtag sind draußen weil sie
eben das genau nicht vermochten diese
mannschaft sollte genau 27 tagen gegen
den weltmeister frankreich anfangen die
herzen der fans zurückzuerobern
bundesligist bayer leverkusen hat einen
neuen trainer der schweizer gerardo
seoane at kommt vom schweizer meister
young boys bern und bekommt einen
vertrag bis 2024 seo an erfolgt auf
hannes wolf der vom dpa ausgeliehen war
und dort hin als u 19 nationaltrainer
zurückkehrt in der englischen premier
league hat der fc chelsea im spiel gegen
leicester city einen großen schritt
gemacht auch nächste saison wieder
champions league zu spielen dank zweier
deutscher em spieler und zur freude von
chelsea coach thomas tuchel verteidiger
antonio rüdiger traf nach ecke mit
oberschenkel zum 1 0 vor erstmals
zugelassenen 8000 zuschauern dann das
foul an timo werner dem rs5 dann
elfmeter folgte dem hoch ein jo-jo kino
sorry verwandelte lesters
anschlusstreffer nur noch kosmetik beim
2 1 sieg der blues die nächste woche
dann auch nach dem champions league
finale steht gegen manchester city
vielen dank danke dir katja so jetzt
haben wir noch ein ganz großes servus
aus österreich für sie in hotels
restaurants cafés kinos heißt es wieder
herzlich willkommen
endlich mal wieder raus oder sogar ein
und das gilt nicht nur für die
österreicher selbst sondern auch für
touristen zum beispiel aus deutschland
zeit für große worte
glücksgefühle fast wie verliebtsein
verliebt im café die lottozahlen und die
lauten 57 14 25 38 45 superzahl 4
weitere gewinnzahlen auf lotto zdf de
und im zdf text auf seite 55 7
ein zwischenhoch morgen kommt ein
zwischenhoch freut sich katja ohne
vergleichen wir können uns alle mit
freunden schönes wort zwischenhoch dann
war das heute schon mal mit der kollegin
marietta slomka um 10 vor 10 heute abend
und uns gibt's morgen wieder wir freuen
uns auf sie bis dann in allen einen
angenehmen abend
[Musik]
meine damen und herren morgen kommt das
zwischenhoch vestner und bringt mehr
sonnenschein und weniger regen heute gab
es ja noch kräftige schauer zum teil
auch gewitter mit hagel die da von west
nach ost über uns hinweg gezogen sind
und mit diesen schauern zum teil auch
gewittern haben wir es jetzt auch noch
am abend und in der nacht zu tun
in einigen regionen ist es dagegen auch
klar die temperaturen sinken auf werte
zwischen 9 grad am oberrhein und drei
grad an den alpen und morgen wird es
dann in einem streifen ungefähr von der
uckermark über die visa bis zum
oberrhein bei 16 bis 18 grad geben sonst
bleibt es kühler
bei 13 bis 15 grad das wetter morgens
nämlich dreigeteilt im südosten gibt es
immer noch kräftige schauer und gewitter
und dann gibt's diesen freundlichen
streifen den bei dem zwischenhoch
verdanken von der küste bis zum
oberrhein im äußersten nordwesten im
emsland sind sie vor einigen schauern
nicht sicher und am nachmittag werden
die wolken von westen noch etwas dichter
am freitag und auch danach geht es doch
sehr wechselhaft weiter vor allen dingen
am samstag wird es dazu an der
nordseeküste sehr stürmisch bei
temperaturen von 12 bis 18 grad